every image you've seen of a black hole
including this one is now science
fiction astronomers have successfully
snapped the first genuine picture of a
black hole
why holes in their own don't look like
very much they don't reflect light
because any light that falls into them
can never escape and they don't emit any
light that we can detect those aren't
the only reasons black holes are hard to
photograph even though they're really
really massive they can be millions or
billions of times the mass of the Sun
they don't take up that much space on
the sky they've compressed all that mass
into a really tiny little space the
closest being black hole to earth is at
the center of the Milky Way which is
26,000 light-years away from us and so
in order to be able to see something
that of that size we need a telescope
that has a resolution that it's powerful
enough that it could see doughnut on the
surface of the Moon black hole
illustrations were all familiar with our
complete lies plenty of data suggests
that black holes exist
some even shoot Jets into space that we
can see in spaghettify stars that get
too close so far the best evidence for
these behemoths has been her entourage
they wrap huge amounts of gas and like
charged plasma around them and as that
stuff is trying to fall into the black
hole can't all go in at once so it
orbits super super super fast and the
friction in that fast
orbiting keeps it white-hot most
illustrations focus on this accretion
disk but now we're looking at the real
thanks to the event horizon telescope or
the eh team
this monumental first image features the
black hole at the center of a galaxy
called m87 at more than 50 million light
years from Earth it's farther away than
the black hole at the centre of the
Milky Way but more massive that makes it
easier to image the picture shows the
shadow of the black hole on the glowing
gas and plasma in the accretion disk the
black hole shadow creates a silhouette
on the disk that outlines the point of
no-return event horizon taking such a
picture requires a really really big
telescope the aged he uses a lot of
smaller radio telescopes instead they
work together using a technique called
very long baseline interferometry and
what that does is it makes those
telescopes kind of act like one giant
telescope scientists analyzing the data
can see how the light waves detected by
each telescope line up with each other
to figure out what's light from the edge
of the black hole and what's known as
the EH T's first image gives us an up
close look at the accretion disk plus
two key bits of information the size and
shape of the black hole shadow and then
that will be enough to answer a lot of
interesting Astrophysical questions
about how life was work how event
horizons worked what is going on there
the big questions include how exactly do
accretion discs form and feed black
holes where the black hole Jets
originate
and the oldy but always a goodie was
Einstein right his general theory of
relativity predicted that event horizons
could conceal tiny massive objects like
black holes the shape of this image that
we see is something that you can predict
using general relativity the EHT is
closed up doesn't defiance time our
understanding of gravity still holds but
there will be more to come the team
hopes to take better and better images
of m87 s black hole and others including
the one at the center of the Milky Way
Sagittarius a star those images might
have something new to say about general
relativity as well as the physics theory
that deals with very small objects
quantum mechanics two of them don't play
well together we don't understand how
gravity works on soar quantum levels and
if we see something that differs from
our expectation that could help point us
to one of many theories that try to
reconcile one of mechanics and general
relativity
[Music]
it's also just cool whether it's a pale
blue dot or pristine portrait of Pluto
seeing has always offered us a new
perspective on the universe humans are
very visual and so we love having images
and I think having an actual picture of
a black hole is gonna blow people's
minds hi I'm Helen I make videos here at
science news this video looks a little
bit familiar to you it's because we
released a version a few weeks ago at
the time we thought that to each these
first image would be a Sagittarius a
star the black hole descent careful
Milky Way but it should not be animating
sevens black hole instead so we decided
to release a new version of the video
with the new results the HT still hopes
to get an image or Sagittarius a star it
just won't be the first image of black
Cola ever released
I don't like break continuity if I roll
up my sleeves and I'm gonna start this
one over this is hard I was just
watching the Great Purge baking show
last night they were the same close two
days in a row we'll go there yeah like
it's wrong
sorry yeah you can cut them like that
you